Let's clear these fractions by multiplying through by 40. I'm going to multiply
the left by 40 and the right by 40. I've multiplied this side by 40 and notice I
didn't need to multiply these inside terms because eventually, this will get
distributed to each of them. I've put parentheses around the right side because
I needed to distribute the 40 to both these terms. 40 times a 4th is 40 4th or
10. I know that because 40 divided by 4 makes 10. This also makes sense because
I can figure out 40 over 1, and then divide 40 and 4 both by 4. And I'll get 10
over 1, or 10. Now, I'm going to distribute or multiply this 10 into this inside
parentheses. I have 10 times negative 2 5th y here, and I have 10 times 1, here.
I can reduce a common factor of 5 in the numerator and the denominator, so I get
negative 4 over 1 or negative 4y. And then, I have my 10 on the end. Notice how
both times I reduced before I multiplied. Usually, it's easier to reduce common
factors before you multiply. Try doing that on this side. If you carry out the
distribution on the right side, what terms would you get down here? Be sure you
enter a number and a variable in the first box and a number in the second box.
You'll also want to include both of their signs. If the term is negative, be
sure to type a negative sign in front of your answer. Good luck.